atout
[Musique]
playstation
nous étions une équipe et elle nous a laissé sans
rien
nous allons mettre fin à cela en commençant maintenant
rapprochez-moi de lui et je m'occuperai
du reste
[Musique]
il se passe quelque chose de bien plus gros
ici
descendez
mat vous avez tout construit vous-même
un artiste peut transformer n'importe quel rebut en
supercar
cet équipage ici c'est l'avenir
nous possédons ces rues et la maison
gagne toujours
nous
l'épidémie de grippe a tué des milliers de personnes à
travers Londres
[Musique] les
gens se débattent dans le désespoir
mais en tant que médecin je sais qu'il y a pire pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
viens
j'ai peu d'alliés et encore moins d'options
c'est une guerre
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
euh
[Musique]
toi